in the last couple videos i talked about
the local linearization of a function
and in terms of graphs there's a nice
interpretation here where if you imagine
the graph of a function and you want to
approximate it near a specific point so
you picture that point somewhere on the
graph and it doesn't have to be there
you know it could choose to be kind of
anywhere else along the graph but if you
have some sort of point and you want to
approximate the function near there you
can have another function whose graph is
just a flat plane and specifically a
plane which is tangent to your original
graph at that point and that's kind of
visually how you think about the local
linearization and what i'm going to
start doing here in this next video and
in the ones following is talking about
quadratic approximations so quadratic
approximations
and these um these basically take this
to the next level and first i'll show
what they look like graphically and then
i'll show you what that actually means
in formulas but graphically instead of
having a plane that's flat you have a
few more parameters to deal with and you
can give yourself some kind of surface
that hugs the graph a little bit more
closely it's still going to be simpler
in terms of formulas it can still be
notably simpler than the original
function but this actually hugs it
closely and as we move around the point
that it's approximating near the way
that it hugs it can look pretty
different
and if you want to think graphically
what a quadratic approximation is you
can basically say if you slice this
surface this kind of ghostly white
surface in any direction it'll look like
a parabola of some kind and notice that
given that we're dealing in multiple
dimensions that can make things look
pretty complicated like this right here
you know if you slice it kind of in this
direction
moving things about
if you look at it from this angle it
kind of looks like a concave up parabola
but if you were looking at it from
another direction it kind of looks
concave down and all in all you get a
surface that actually has quite a bit of
information carried within it and you
can see that by hugging the graph very
closely this approximation is going to
be well it's going to be even closer
because near the point where you're
approximating you can go out you can
take a couple steps away and the
approximation is still going to be very
close to what the graph is and it's only
when you step really far away from the
original point that the approximation
starts to deviate away from the graph
itself so this is going to be something
that although it takes more information
to describe than a local linearization
it gives us a much closer approximation
so a linear function which you know one
that just draws a plane like this in
terms of actual functions what this
means so i'll kind of write
linear
this is going to be some kind of
function
of x and y
and what it looks like is some kind of
constant which i'll say a
plus another constant times the variable
x
y this is sort of the basic form of
linear functions and technically this
isn't linear if one was going to be
really pedantic they would say that
that's actually affine because strictly
speaking linear functions shouldn't have
this constant term it should be purely
x's and y's but in the context of
approximations people usually usually
would call this the linear term so
quadratic term what this is going to
look like quadratic
we are allowed to have all the same
terms as that linear one so you can have
you know a constant you can have these
two linear terms b x and c y and then
you're allowed to have anything that has
two variables multiplied into it so
maybe i'll have d times x squared and
then you can also have something times x
y this is considered a quadratic term
which is a little bit weird at first
because usually we think of quadratics
as associated with that exponent two but
really it's just saying anytime you have
two variables multiplied in
and then we can add some other constant
say f times y squared where you know now
we're multiplying two y's into it so all
of these guys these are what you would
call your quadratic terms things that
you know either x squared y squared or x
times y anything that has two variables
in it so you can see this gives us a lot
more control because previously as we
tweaked the constants a b and c
you're able to get yourself you know
that gives you control over all sorts of
planes in space and if you choose the
most optimal one you'll get one that's
tangent to your curve at the specific
point and kind of it'll depend on where
that point is you'll get different
planes but they're all tangent so what
we're going to do in the next couple
videos is talk about how you tweak all
of these six different constants so that
you can get functions that really
closely hug the curve right and as you
they're all going to depend on the
original point because as you move that
point around what it takes to hug the
curve is going to be different
it's going to have to do with partial
differential information about your
original function the function whose
graph this is and it's going to look
pretty similar to the local
linearization case just you know added
complexity so we have to add a few more
steps in there and i'll see you next
video talking about that